[Applaudissements]
la vérité avec Pascal et laence ce soir
vous avez Gilles Verdez je vous le
laisse mais qui doit dire une vérité à
Gilles c'est Gill
quiér pe voir danséc on peut voir dans
l'écran qui est derrière s'il vous plaît
ah bah
oui je vous le confirme je vous le
confirme c'est lui sur twitch
allez alors ben mesdames et messieurs on
vous demande d'accueillir Gilles qui a
une vérité à dire ce soir qui BC la
vérité qui compte ou si ça concerne si
ça concerne sa coiffure on a pas besoin
qu'il parle on l'a vu c'est quelque
chose en fait à à demander à Cyril
Hanouna ah une augmentation alors
d'abord on va voir si j'ouvre le rideau
ou pas vous ferez ce que vous voudrez
estce que vous êtes vous êtes surpris
que ce soit G pens que c'éta à moi
charou parler je pensais pas que cétait
ça me concernait déclaration g je suis
un peu ému Cyril ah ouais mais je vais
vous parler avec mon cœur non mais pour
l'instant je' je'ai pas je'
vas-y vas-y après j'ai si j'ouvre le
rideau ou pas vous pouvez me le
laisserjà
d'accord bien sûr c'est quelqu'un que
j'ai j'apprécie après voilà c'est
quelqu'un que j'ai perdu de vue
euh mais avec le temps on a pris des
chemins différents voilà lui voilà mais
avec plaisir avec plaisir je m'attendais
pas du tout à lui je pour dire la vérité
en fait depuis quelques jours je revis
non euh vous ne l'avez peut-être pas vu
mais je sors d'une période difficile ah
ouais et euh en ce moment de puis
notamment le début de semaine ça va
mieux Cyr ça va mieux grâce à vous la
semaine dernière vous avez fait une
promesse à quelqu'un que j'aime beaucoup
et vous avez tenu cette
promesse vous avez dit à Hugo manos
qu'il viendrait plus souvent c'était fin
de semaine dernière ou et depuis le
début de cette semaine Hugo mano c'est
là très souvent donc qu'est-ce que tu
veux me dire tu veux bouffer le cul du
G si je suis là c'est parce que j'ai une
demande à vous ah d'accord très bien
vasy et si vous répondez favorablement à
cette demande peut-être que vous
ouvrirez le rideau Fatou te regarde
Fatou nous regarde évidemment mais ma
demande n'est pas liée à Fatou ah Cyril
si jamais vous
acceptez à partir de début janvier c'est
ma demande j'aimerais qu'à partir de
début janvier Hugo mano soit là tout le
temps et si vous acceptez si vous ouvrez
le rideau je m'engage à payer la moitié
de sa pige pour que Jacques cardos ne
soit plus jamais
là
j'étais limitem en fait c'est très drôle
très drôle mais malheureusement moi je
je je fais le je fais le jeu je le fais
vraiment premier degré Jill merci de
t'être exprimé malheureusement je je ne
vais pas ouvrir le rideau je comprends
par que non non alors j'adore voulez
petit ver d'au pour prendre votre
décision non il va en faire plus mais il
y a pas tellement de suspense Gill oui
c'est non malheureusement d'accord pas
de problèmeess merci mais c'était sympa
c'était drôle ah ouais çait bien mais ça
se termine mal désolé vas-y vas-y Gill
qui vient d'économiser la matié de son
salaire exactement merci non mais
c'était pas
mal vas-y tu tu veux tu vas y aller à ce
rythme là bah je fais ce que je peux non
mais attendez attendez Jean-M Jean-M
Jean jean- une seconde c'est pas la même
daupe que ce qu'on vient d'entendre là
quand même c'est un peu plus je craim
malheureusement qu'on soit dans le même
registre non mais qui a un vrai bail qui
a un vrai bail parce queil y a Pascal
Pascal vas-y vas-y Pascal pourquoi c'est
moi il y a Pascal Hugo Pascal Hugo
Pascal allez-y on va voir on va voir t
il a plus de talent non mais allez-y
allez-y vousz vous étiz Pascal Hugo
Polska allez-y allez-y des choses à dire
et vous voulez pas un peu vous dépêcher
s'il vous plaît mais attendez je suis à
fond musique c'est bien non c'était une
demande qui concernait
Raymon quoi je voulais savoir si vous
accepteriez de lui dégonfler le melon
même si c'est votre fils spirituel parce
qu'il vraiment depuis quelques moi il ne
se sent plus pissé ouais ça en vient
maintenant et ça ça met ça met en péril
pritmission l'esprit d'émission l'esprit
de famille d'émission il accepte de
rentrer sur le plateau qu'à la fin une
fois tout le monde est assis une fois
que le chauffeur de salle est consacré
uniquement sur lui et il vient il sert
la main de tout monde comme ça juste
avant vous il se prend pour pours donc
vraimentend tu descendes viment étage
voilà donc c pas ouf heureusement qu'
pas allé non vraiment heureusement
vraiment qui est pas allé heureusement
allez qui on a derrière le rideau qui on
va découvrir qui se tientrire alors le
rideau c'est notre ami Pascal Pascal
vous savez que vousentend très mal hein
mais tu es juste là comment tu l'entends
mal fr attend je send l'oreille alors
vas-y alors Pascal euh qui avez-vous
voulu inviter ce soir sur notre plateau
et pour lui dire quoi quoi et bien ce
soir j'ai décidé d'inviter Raymon sur le
plateau fort c'est pas vrai j'avais une
question à poser à Raymon vous
connaissez vous connaissez Raymon depuis
combien de temps pascal je connais
Raymon depuis extrêmement longtemps et
quel type de relation vous avez avec lui
très amical et professionnel il y a
jamais eu plus si mois non est-ce qu'il
a tenté on parle bien du même Raymon on
parle du même Raymon oui d'accord est-ce
qu'il a tenté depuis très longtemps 4
mois au moin c'est court déjà enceinte
cours ça pas
c'est c'est c'est c'est bien j'ai bien
entendu la question h c'est Pascal qui
l'a posé ah c'est moi qui ai posé la
question non j'ai pas encore posé
assume ce que tu dis quand bon non non
non je parler à
Laurent est-ce que vous êtes prêt à
entendre ce que Pascal la tour
du Pascal de la tour
du entend alors estce que vous êtes prêt
à écouter ce que Pascal est V bien
j'aime bien le risque j'aime bien j'aime
bien rigoler j'adore Pascal donc je suis
prêt à écouter ce que Pascal tu fais une
tête elle va pas dire qu'elle entend
fond de
toi je te
dis fait s déc ilit
une va lui dire non mais frère ça va
t'inquiète pas vous êtes surpris de la
voir dans surpr à côté 2
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
minutes
làou mais c'est
fouou on rit beaucoup de votre
il du drame derrière écter ce que PASC
sérieux je veux bien écouter ce que
Pascal a me dire ce soir Pascal ma
chérie c'est à vous bien r il y a un
drame épouvantable rmon pourquoi m'astu
invité à dîner deux fois pourquoi et il
a jamais eu de dîner c'est
pasa d' c'était son
cl et on doit répondre là comme ça alors
c'est quoi ta question alors c'est ça ta
question ça pourquoi je l'ai jamais
invité c'est quoi votre demande pas tu
m'as invité à dîner deux fois ro non
mais la la question c'est est-ce que tu
qui ve peut t'invit à dîner pourquoi
m'astu invité à dîner Réo deux fois
parce que je t'avais dit que on irait
dîner ensemble avec un ami qui voulait
te rencontrer tu te rappelles ou pas ah
d'accord et après excuse-moi mais c'est
ouis arrête mais ce my tu le fais encore
s décon attend
il Sarah Salman il l'avait invitéon
parce qu'il y avait un ami auss mais
frère
e tu es réi toi tu es sans famille tu es
sans amis on très bien un
peu après on on a pas eu le temps mais
c'est vrai qu'on doit aller dîner avec
Pascal alors mais Pascal donc ta
question c'est est-ce que tu veux est-ce
qu'il veut t'inviter à dîner c'est ça il
t'ouvre le r ouais pourquoi m'invite à
dîner mais est-ce qu'elle dirait oui le
projet quel était le projet c'est quoi
le projet quel était le projet attends
pascal tu as dîné avec lui ou pas cétait
pas pour parler de et pourquoi tu as dit
non à chaque fois il te plaît pas mais
mais non je pose la question pourquoi la
question c'est
pas do on doit caler doit caler ce dîner
Pascal Calon ce dîner on doit caler tous
les jours mais vous encore caler un
dîner pour qu'il y ait quand même un
enjeu il Pascal est-ce que est-ce que la
question est est-ce que tu es d'accord
Rimon pour venir pour aller dîner avec
moi moi je pose pas la question mais
c'est la principe espèce
c'est pas possible de pourquoi je l'ai
ramené Mar reprends là
[Applaudissements]
bordel bon écoute alors que tu l'invites
à dîner c'est ça la question on est
d'accord d on alors tu dis OUI tu ouv le
rideau oui voilà il t'invite à dîner
allez c'est bon
allez oh
là il est fouche allez là merci allez
prochaine personne derrière le rideau
c'est qui derrière le rideau c'est qui
la question c'était peut-être est-ce que
tu payeras le dîner ouais c'est ça oui
qui est derrière ride attends qui est
derrière le rideau ou oh sérieux
délireonte bonjour excuse-moi tu crois
quoi tu crois que c'est des photos de
charme ou quoi là c'est cru sur Mims
celui-là sur ma vie croyais qu'il est
sur
MIM mais lui Hugo manos tu le vois comme
ça on dirait un réparateur dans un film
érotique
sur la vie de ma mère normalement il
arrive bonjour madame bonsoir madame on
m'a dit que vous aviez un problème avec
votre ordinateur c'est vrai c'est vrai
hein oui je suis effectivement dans
l'informatique oh oui oh oui une outil
contrôle alt plus
supprimé que se passe-t-il non mais sans
rigoler tiens-toi correctement mon bébé
Hugo bonjour bonjoury Vous faites quoi
dans la vie Hugo je suis chroniqueur
chez l'animateur numéro
1 plisir c'est
beau Laurent regarde l'émission et je
suis le compagnon de l'an inumateur
numéro 1 bis voil il est bien il
est qui avezvous une vérité à dire Hugo
ce soir à cyil Anouna ah
mer vous connaissez C vous connaissez
Hugo très
peu
déj on on a déjà fait une soirée
ensemble je l'aime beaucoup alors je l'
non non non je l'aime beaucoup c'est
vraiment devenu quelqu'un qui qui compte
beaucoup pour moi et il sait que j'ai
j'ai je l'aime vraiment beaucoup c'est
vraiment sincère moi aussi voilà je je
peux vous parler vous êtes prêt à
écouter pour demander de l'oseille on
arrête tout de suite c'est presque ça je
la sens pas je t assz senti les gars je
le sens c'est quoi qu'est-ce que tu veux
j'ai pêché qu'est-ce que tu as fait ah
j'ai pas pêché pêché j'ai pêché je je je
vais vous raconter une petite anecdote
qui date de cet été au mois d'août non
euh nous avons dit à l'antenne un peu
avant les vacances que nous allions
partir à miconos ensemble je sais pas si
vous vous rappelez cyil sûr ouais voilà
ça fait tous les ans qu'on dit ça voilà
donc le public une partie du public
était donc persuadé que nous étions
ensemble à miconos à miconos ouais et
quand j'ai été à miconos j'ai été
contacté sur les réseaux sociaux par
l'un des meilleurs restaurants de
Mikonos qui coûte relativement cher
s'appelle comment le rest je pas donneré
le nom parce que la suite de l'histoire
peut-êtrec voilà euh je culpabilise un
peu donc c'est pas facile à à raconter
comme histoire et donc ils m'ont dit
voilà vous êtes avec Cyril amiconos nous
adorons Cyril et nous aimerions beaucoup
avoir une photo avec lui pour cela nous
sommes dans la possibilité de vous
offrir une table complète entrée plat
dessert boisson voilà donc c'est une
grande tablée vous êtes un grand groupe
d'amis puisquil me semble que vous êtes
8 ou neu est-ce que vous accepteriez de
venir avec Cyril me faisant comprendre
que la condition cinequanon c'était
vraiment votre présence
d'accord j'ai dit oui j'ai dit oui parce
que je savais que c'était une table qui
allait coûteré très cher ou j'ai pêché
par Avaris je je me suis présenté au
restaurant avec mes amis en disant que
vous alliez arrivé incessamment sous peu
fait comme rmon avec les meufs quoi en
fait nous nous sommes remplis la pense
toute la soirée oui et vous n'êtes
jamais arrivé puisque vous n'étiez pas
Mikonos donc j'ai utilisé un mensonge
mais pas fait payer comment t'ont pas
fait payer B non du coup sur le fait à
la fin vu que c'était prévu que ça
devait être gratuit je n'ai pas payé en
gros j'ai utilisé votre nom ah ou pour
pour un gain personnel et c'est vraiment
pas cool VO m'endais un truc plus grave
ouais mais quand même c'est quelque
chose de franchement
non est-ce que vous auriez fait la même
chose c
ouire
j'accepte exc j'accepte ses excuses
j'ouvre le rideau bien
entend
normal ce soir auss parce que bien sûr
faites MD faitesle pard